My ecologist is telling me that no one with cancer should be on an acetylocysteine.
What are your thoughts as to keep taking it or not?
Also you put me on a comelpro twice a day after taking the ebidose my kidney cert and trying
to drink a large glass of water with the tablet, but I'm not dehydrated.
So that can be an effect of this because it's a very strong, different type of herb.
That can be really good for your cancer so make sure you're drinking, I would just keep
doing that.
That is the recommended dose so I would not lower the dose on that.
Far as this question of why the ecologist say no one should be on an acetylocysteine, the
only thing I could think of, I'm trying to get into his head and think of why he would
say that.
So an acetylocysteine, it's a very strong anti-oxidant.
Now an ecologist is usually giving what, chemotherapy, what is chemotherapy, an oxidizing agent?
What is an oxidizing agent, a poison, what that mean, that's just what an oxidizing agent
is.
It's a poison.
The truth is, we need oxidizing agents in our body.
The problem is we get way too many oxidizing agents, what do oxidizing agents in our body
do?
Remember I've said over and over again that don't list things as good versus bad.
I mean, things are good versus bad if they're out of balance, right?
So God created us that we need oxidizing agents, what do oxidizing agents do?
Oxidation in our body kills pathogens, period.
That's what it does.
Oxidation kills pathogens.
Our immune system kills pathogens.
Oxidation also can help kill cells that are damaged too.
So the idea of why do we give an oxidizing agent, a poison to a person with chemotherapy,
or personally with cancer, calling it chemotherapy, is really because the idea is that cancer cells
are going to be less stable than healthy cells.
And they won't be as able to withstand a chemical poisoning.
So if we poison this person, the cancer cells will die first.
That's quite honestly, that is the truth.
That is the simple explanation of chemotherapy.
And I don't say that to knock it because it could be a huge blessing because lots of times
it works exactly that way.
So but enacetyl cysteine isn't antioxidant.
Enacetyl cysteine isn't antioxidant.
It works as an antioxidant itself.
It helps form glutathione.
It gives off the cysteine for glutathione reformation after glutathione is oxidized in the process
of acted as an antioxidant.
So glutathione is recharged and recycled inside the cell.
And it needs cysteine to do that.
Enacetyl cysteine really helps with that.
So my thought is that an oncologist is saying no cancer patient really should be on any antioxidants.
And what he's saying is that because I'm giving them chemotherapy, I don't want them taking
the antioxidants.
So that's why he's saying it, at least that's why I think he's saying it because there's
any further sense in saying that.
So again, what we tell people is if you're going to do chemotherapy, if you're doing chemotherapy
infusions, don't take antioxidants for 24 hours because that's really what the chemotherapy
is really actively killing cancer cells.
If it's not killing, beyond that it's just damaging healthy cells and you should be taking
antioxidants to protect your healthy cells.
And in fact, the number one reason why a person got cancer in the first place is because
of a deficiency in antioxidants.
Why do you say that?
Because what's the number one cause of cancer?
Remember I said, heavy metals, toxins, pesticides, mycotoxins, getting inside the cells and
damaging the DNA of the cell.
What are those things that I just mentioned?
Are oxidizing agents?
That's what they're doing.
And they're actually oxidizing.
That's the process of the damage when I say, damaging the DNA.
It's an oxidative process.
So if we all had more than adequate antioxidants every second of every day, the chance of us
getting cancer quite honestly would diminish greatly.
So to say that no cancer patients should be on antioxidants is like you're just cursing
that person to not be able to fight off further cancers, not be able to fight off stance cancer
stem cell circulated tumor cells that want to raise a hole in another place in your body,
not being able to really win the battle that they're trying to win.
So it's just ridiculous.
So I would agree with the oncologist that a person with cancer should not take antioxidants
for 48 hours after their IV infusion.
And after that, you should load up on antioxidants, glutathione, alpha-pecac acid, curcumin, vitamin
C, all these great antioxidants that we are.
So I wouldn't say we're deficient in antioxidants as a nation, as a human race.
I would say that we are overabunded in oxidizing agents.
So remember I said it's balance, right?
We need some balance of oxidation taking place in our body, but the problem is we are
so out of balance, because we are exposure to chemicals and heavy metals and poisons in
our environment to toxins and these chemical companies didn't exist 150 years ago.
Now we're kicking on all this stuff and causing just damage to ourselves and we don't even
know it.
Really important that we are taking antioxidant nutrition to help our body fight this.